[Musique]
les séances est ouvertes
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de loi visant à protéger
les logements contre l'occupation
illicite
bonjour et bienvenue dans les grands
débats aujourd'hui retour sur la
proposition de loi pour lutter contre
les squatteurs elle prévoit de triplés
les sanctions en cas d'occupation
illicite d'un logement jusqu'à trois ans
de prison et 45000 euros d'amende
au-delà des squatteurs le texte vise
aussi les locataires qui ne payent plus
leur loyer la résiliation de leur bail
et leur expulsion sans passer par la
case justice seront facilités c'est une
idée du député Renaissance Guillaume
kasbarion fin novembre pour la première
fois il la défend à la tribune de
l'Assemblée
[Musique]
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
Cécilia en procédure avec ses locataires
depuis 6 ans a dû déménager dans une
petite maison rurale elle n'arrivait
plus à faire face aux 75000 euros d'un
pays 25000 euros de charges 7000 euros
d'honoraires d'avocats que du coup de
son appartement occupé en région
parisienne
Mégane dans la Somme qui a hérité de la
maison de sa mère décédée en février est
actuellement hébergé par des amis sa
maison est occupée par un locataire qui
ne paye plus son loyer depuis 15 mois
pierre et Maryse à Marseille ont dû
vivre dans un camping-car pendant plus
de deux ans il n'arrivait plus à vivre
décemment car leur locataire n'avait pas
réglé de loyer depuis deux ans
nous avons tous déjà reçu dans nos
permanences en circonscription des
petits propriétaires qui ne roulent pas
sur l'or ils ont parfois hérité de la
maison familiale ils ont parfois acheté
ce bien à la sueur de leur front ils se
sont parfois endettés pour financer ce
logement et il se retrouve du jour au
lendemain victime de squats ou de
procédures Kaf Cayenne en raison d'un
pays qui dure depuis des années ces
situations elles sont insupportables
d'une part car elle prolonge et elle
plonge dans la précarité des citoyens
pourtant qui travaillent dur et qui
respectent les règles d'autre part car
elle touche un principe fondamental que
certains ont parfois tendance à oublier
celui du respect de droit de propriété
droit inviolable et sacré inscrit à
l'article 17 de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme
face à ces situations intolérables qui
est gratine et graines nos actualités
locales et suscitent l'indignation de
nos concitoyens nous avons déjà agi avec
fermeté après la création d'une
procédure accélérée d'expulsion des
squatteurs en 2007 celle-ci n'avait plus
été modifiée et fonctionnait mal nous
avons repris le sujet dans la loi ASAP
en 2020 ce qui nous a permis de mener à
bien 170 expulsions de squatteurs sur ce
fondement en 2021 mais l'actualité nous
a montré maintes et maintes fois qu'il
faut aller plus loin ou en tout cas
aborder plus globalement le problème
c'est ce que permet cette proposition de
loi du groupe Renaissance que nous
examinons aujourd'hui la première partie
du texte a d'ailleurs été largement
enrichi en commission notamment avec des
apports de nos collègues des groupes
Renaissance CLR de nouveaux articles ont
été créés qui permettent entre autres de
mieux caractériser le délit de squat et
de veiller à protéger les propriétaires
contre les dépenses d'entretien
excessives qui sont nés des situations
de squat deux autres articles permettent
d'améliorer la lutte contre les
marchands de sommeil et en sanctionnant
les faux propriétaires qui exploitent
les une vulnérable et de renforcer la
lutte contre le squat en assurant une
meilleure utilisation collective des
immeubles vacants au-delà de ces cas de
squats toute une zone grise n'est pas
traitée par le biais des procédures
existantes je pense par exemple au refus
de payer partiellement ou dans son
intégralité de loyer qui peut grever
pendant des mois ou des années la
situation financière d'un petit bailleur
dans le logement constitue un complément
de retraite ou encore le refus des de
quitter les lieux en fin de bail quand
le bailleur souhaite récupérer pour
lui-même ou pour un membre de sa famille
contraignant ainsi le bailleur à
déménager ou à faire héberger ses
enfants
oui la plupart des locations se passent
très bien et pour elle la propager de
loi n'aura aucun impact mais pour mieux
protéger tous les autres locataires
il faut que nous agissions nous devons
protéger contre les comportements
abusifs de la part d'une minorité de
locataires qui doivent être mieux
sanctionnées ces comportements
augmentent l'appréhension et les
exigences des bailleurs ou décourage des
bailleurs de mettre en location leur
bien si nous avons un marché locatif
tellement engorgé par des demandes dans
tous les sens par des certificats des
garanties des cautions des attestations
des justificatifs c'est qu'il n'y a pas
assez de confiance entre les bailleurs
et les locataires si nous réussissons à
rétablir cette confiance il deviendra
vite possible de diminuer les exigences
des bailleurs ce qui savent cette
confiance se sont les cas d'une minorité
de locataires indélicat qui continue
d'occuper un logement parfois malgré la
décision d'un juge de rompre le bail et
de procéder à l'expulsion qui en payent
les conséquences l'immense majorité des
locataires bon payeurs
au-delà de leur coût humain immédiats
les lenteurs et les manques de
réactivité des procédures tout au long
du règlement des conflits dans les
rapports locatifs entame la confiance
qu'on en concitoyens dans la justice et
dans nos institutions c'est la raison
pour laquelle la proposition de loi
traite des relations entre le locataire
et le bailleur ces dernières années nous
avons porté une grande attention à la
sécurisation des locataires
l'encadrement des loyers en zone tendue
que nous avons créé en 2018 dans la loi
Elan il a été prorogé jusqu'en 2026 par
la loi 3DS en février dernier nous avons
étendu visale lancé aussi en 2018 pour
permettre un cautionnement plus fiable
des locataires encore il y a quelques
mois dans la loi sur le pouvoir d'achat
nous avons plafonné l'évolution de la
hausse des loyers en dessous du niveau
de l'inflation nous attendons aussi des
efforts importants des propriétaires en
matière de mise à niveau énergétique du
parc locatif je rappelle que toutes les
passoires thermiques seront concernées
d'ici 2025 et 2028 c'est-à-dire au bas
mot 1,5 millions de logements dans le
parc locatif privé
la proposition de loi s’inscrit donc
dans la recherche d'un équilibre entre
les protections accordées au locataires
et les efforts supplémentaires
demandaient aux bailleurs dans un
contexte tendu il est important
d'envoyer un signal au bailleur afin de
ne pas désinciter leurs investissements
c'est d'autant plus vrai que les options
s'offront aux investisseurs sont simples
à réaliser à commencer par le parc des
meublés de tourisme ou celui des
résidences services voilà pourquoi il me
semble impératif d'agir avec vigueur
pour remédier à ses injustices et c'est
le sens de cette proposition de loi nous
ne supprimons aucune des étapes de la
procédure du contentieux locatif nous
proposons simplement des accélérations
de procédure pour aller plus vite vers
des décisions exécutoires car nous
pensons que les procès et procédures qui
durent des années et des années ne sont
positifs pour personne en commission de
nombreux amendements ont renforcé le
texte en favorisant l'accélération des
procédures nous avons également amélioré
la capacité du juge à apprécier la
situation du locataire pour distinguer
entre celui qui est de bonne foi et
celui qui est de mauvaise foi et c'est
un travail que je l'espère nous allons
pouvoir poursuivre en séance comme en
commission les amendements déposés pour
la séance témoignent de position
idéologique qui peuvent être
radicalement différentes en lisant
certains amendements des groupes LFI et
écologistes j'ai l'impression que
certains veulent défendre les squats
allonger les procédures ou simplement de
veulent pas parler de ces petits
propriétaires en difficulté au simple
motifs qu'ils sont propriétaires celles
et ceux d'entre vous qui ont reçu un
jour dans leur permanence un citoyen
dans le domicile esquatté ou un
propriétaire dont le bien est occupé par
un locataire qui ne paye plus depuis des
années savent que la situation actuelle
ne peut plus durer nous avons le devoir
d'agir c'est ce qu'attendent les
victimes c'est ce qu'attendre les
Français je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
la dernière loi régissant les procédures
d'expulsion date seulement de 2020 mais
elle est mal appliquée faute de moyens
suffisant pour déloger les squatteurs
alors le ministre de la Justice Eric
Dupont-Moretti parle d'un monde à
l'envers et défend une nouvelle réforme
indispensable
Josette d'emblée très claire
ne s'agit pas ici
de favoriser de riches propriétaires des
rentiers qui exploiteraient des gens
démunis mais bien tout simplement de
faire respecter notre droit et de faire
cesser l'affaissement de l'autorité de
l'État que toutes les affaires
médiatisées ont gravement mis à mal
ces situations ont souvent mises en
lumière des petits propriétaires ayant
économisé toute leur vie pour acquérir
un bien
et il se retrouve dans l'impossibilité
de récupérer le fruit de leur travail et
de leurs économies votre proposition de
loi
propose d'augmenter les peines encourus
pour la violation domicile afin de les
aligner sur celles encourues par le
propriétaire qui par exemple rentre chez
lui
à l'aide de manœuvre dans le but bien
sûr de récupérer son bien
c'est le monde à l'envers
c'est le monde à l'envers et et pire que
cela
des informations me sont remontées selon
lesquelles le squatteur a le cynisme
parfois de faire afficher sur la fenêtre
du domicile qui l'occupe les pénalités
qui seraient encourues par le
propriétaire on marche sur la tête
je suis donc et vous l'avez compris mais
tout à fait favorable à cette alignement
dans l'échelle des peines il me semble
en effet nécessaire et ça permet de
répondre à une situation qu'on ne peut
tous que qualifier de totalement injuste
je suis en revanche il fallait un bémol
un peu plus réservé sur l'article 2 de
la proposition de loin qui vise à
clarifier les notions utilisées dans
l'infraction de violation de missiles en
élargissant la notion de domicile à
celle de domicile vide
de meubles
à cet égard un bien immobilier ne peut
être considéré comme un domicile s'il ne
comporte pas des éléments minimaux
nécessaires à l'habitation ça soulève
des difficultés d'ordre constitutionnel
car portant atteinte au sens du délit de
violation domicile qui vise à protéger
je l'ai rappelé tout à l'heure la vie
privée est familiale et non pas le droit
de propriété l'extension de la notion de
domicile à la résidence secondaire ne
pose en revanche pas de problème car le
domicile est déjà interprété de cette
manière par la jurisprudence j'ai donc
bon espoir que nos débats nous
permettront d'avancer sur ce point
je vais également
faire part ici
de mes fortes réserves quant à l'article
1a des travaux de votre commission qui
prévoit la création d'un délit général
d'occupation sans droit ni titre de
mauvaise foi d'un immeuble d'habitation
en premier lieu il présente
d'importantes fragilités
constitutionnelle au regard du principe
de l'égalité des délits qui impose en
effet de définir clairement le champ
d'application de l'infraction et vous
m'accorderez que le terme de mauvaise
foi ne fait pas l'objet d'une définition
en droit pénal en deuxième la mauvaise
foi oui je le confirme monsieur le
député Maya ça existe partout d'ailleurs
sauf dans l'hémicycle naturellement
en deuxième lieu le champ d'application
de ce daily m'apparaît trop large voire
excessif ce délit aurait également pour
effet d'incriminer les locataires
défaillants qui ne font l'objet d'aucune
mesure d'expulsion y compris y compris
pendant la trêve hivernale et y compris
si aucune procédure d'expulsion n'a été
lancé à leur rencontre enfin en dernier
lieu cet article procède un renversement
de la charge de la preuve et instaure de
ce fait une présomption de culpabilité
un tel dispositif présente un risque
constitutionnel extrêmement important
en complément
des outils offerts par notre procédure
pénale nous disposons de deux voies pour
expulser le squatteur du logement
d'autrui une voie civile une voie
administrative la voici ville permet de
saisir le juge des référés celui-ci
lorsqu'il constate l'existence d'un
trouble manifestement illicite
c'est-à-dire l'occupation du bien peut
ordonner les mesures conservatoires qui
s'imposent y compris l'expulsion selon
les données statistiques de 2021 le
délai moyen de traitement d'une demande
d'expulsion d'un squatteur devant le
juge judiciaire et de 5 mois nous
disposons également depuis la loi DALO
du 5 mars 2007 d'une procédure
administrative d'exécution forcée
celle-ci permet dans son article 38 au
préfet lorsqu'une plainte a été déposée
pour violation de domicile d'ordonner
l'expulsion des squatteurs sans attendre
qu'une décision judiciaire soit rendue
à la suite de l'entrée en vigueur de la
loi ASAP qui est venu compléter la loi
DALO nous avons pris l'initiative avec
mes collègues des ministères de
l'Intérieur et du Logement d'adresser le
22 janvier 2021 une instruction au
préfet pour détailler la mise en œuvre
de cette procédure et les enjoindre à
assurer la rapidité de son exécution
plus que jamais l'exécutif est donc
mobilisé pour lutter contre les squats
la présence proposition de loi en temps
renforcer la procédure administrative
afin de faciliter l'expulsion des
occupants sans droit ni titres il me
semble toutefois nécessaire de veiller à
ce que ces nouveaux dispositifs ne
puissent pas avoir des conséquences sur
les locataires de bonne foi qui peuvent
se trouver dans une situation économique
délicate et qu'il est indispensable de
ne pas pointer du doigt dans un contexte
économique incertain c'est pourquoi
il est indispensable de garder à
l'esprit que notre droit civil veille à
aménager les droits des locataires qui
ne paient plus leur loyer en permettant
notamment au juge après la délivrance
d'un commandement de quitter les lieux
d'octroyer de façon exceptionnelle de
délai supplémentaires afin de permettre
à des familles en situation de précarité
de se reloger dans des conditions dignes
le droit civil fait également obstacle
aux expulsions durant la trêve hivernale
c'est qui non négligeable j'insiste sur
ce point car la loi veille ainsi à
répondre à des situations individuelles
qui peuvent se révéler dramatiques et il
n'apparaît pas souhaitable que la
légitime lutte contre les squatteurs
conduisent à modifier ses équilibres à
ce titre votre proposition de loi
prévoit la réduction de certains délais
de procédures destinés à accélérer le
traitement de ses affaires il ne
bouleverse pas l'équilibre des droits en
présence et j'y suis donc tout à fait
favorable je l'ai dit dans la lutte
contre les squats ce texte est une
nouvelle étape intéressante faisons en
sorte tous ensemble
ça arrive ça nous est arrivé il y a de
cela quelques jours je devrais dire
quelques heures qu'il apporte ce texte
des solutions efficaces concrètes
respectueuse de nos grands principes
constitutionnels voilà Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés ce que trop
longuement sans doute je vous les
exprimer pour le gouvernement
la nupesse s'insurge contre ce qu'elle
considère comme un grave recul du droit
au logement devant l'Assemblée nationale
ce sont les associations à qui
manifestent pour dénoncer un texte
honteux qui va accélérer les expulsions
les députés de gauche eux ferraille dans
les missile
madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues nous
n'accepterons pas que l'on considère
comme des coupables ceux qui dans la
nécessité d'éviter la maladie et
peut-être la mort
occupe des logements vacants ces mots ne
sont pas de nous ils sont dans la
relation collègues qui siégeait ici son
nom c'était Henri grouas il était plus
connu sous le nom de l'abbé Pierre ces
mots il les prononça un jour de décembre
1994 rue du Dragon à Paris alors qu'il
venait soutenir des militants du droit
au logement et des familles qui avaient
réquisitionné un bâtiment vide de la
Cogedim
ces mots de l'un des pierres il les dit
parce qu'il disait à ce genre que leur
cause était juste et que quand les
institutions ne font rien il n'y a
d'autre choix que de s'abriter là où
l'on peut en introduisant le fait
qu'occuper tout type de logement
vacances à parenthe à un vol avec 3 ans
à 15 ans de prison ferme vous glissez
monsieur le rapporteur sur une pente
dangereuse qui n'est pas contrairement à
ce que vous avancez la protection des
petits propriétaires mais la
criminalisation de tous les mal logés
autrement dit
si votre loi était passée jadis l'abbé
Pierre serait en prison pourtant nous
aurions espéré que dans un pays qui
compte 4,1 million de mal logés 3005 ans
sans abri dont 42 000 enfants SDF vous
nous proposeriez enfin une loi à la
hauteur des enjeux de mal logement au
lieu de quoi va priorité de répondre à
la médiatisation constante c'est dans
l'exposé des motifs d'un épiphénomène
les affaires de squat ne concernent que
0,05% des logements recensés dans ce
pays
170 affaires par an c'est autant que le
nombre de députés Renaissance
170 affaires par an c'est 100 fois moins
que les expulsions locatives madame
wargon elle-même ministre du Logement a
signifié que c'était un problème mineur
qui ne méritait pas
d'instrumentalisation politique madame
Causse ancienne ministre du Logement dit
de votre loi qu'elle va déréguler des
années de travail sur la prévention des
impulsion vous devriez leur prêter une
oreille plus attentive qu'aux éditoriaux
de cnews oui il est évident ici pour
tout le monde qu'il est inacceptable de
rentrer chez soi et découvrir des gens
qui s'y sont installés c'est tellement
inacceptable que nos anciens ont déjà
légiféré sur le sujet ça a été dit avec
une loi qui sanctionne l'occupation du
domicile d'autrui avec un an de prison
et 15000 euros d'amende la loi actuelle
prévoit d'ailleurs son délai l'expulsion
des gens
occupant le démission le domicile
résidence secondaire ou principale la
notion de domicile est ainsi protégée
nettement et ce n'est pas de ce type de
squat dans ce préoccupe d'ailleurs votre
loi non c'est surtout toutes les autres
personnes qui sont juridiquement sans
droit ni titre et victime du mal
logement qui sont visés qui
protégez-vous réellement pas les petits
retraités propriétaires bailleurs comme
vous dites sinon vous auriez proposé la
garantie universelle des loyers où
l'augmentation des pensions de retraite
non vous protéger les intérêts des
multiples propriétaires qui détiennent à
eux seuls plus de 75% du parc locatif
cela car avec votre loi le domicile est
désormais dissocié de la notion de lieu
de vie un gros propriétaire pour la
prétendre qu'un logement vide non meublé
ou encore des immeubles de bureau
vacants les salades sont son domicile
bienvenue en Absurdistan
voici désormais quelques exemples
concrets reçus dans nos permanences de
gens qui avec votre loi vont se
retrouver comme squatteur et même voleur
Guillaume était étudiant droit arrivée
dans une grande ville qu'il ne connaît
pas il a trouvé un logement une
sous-location un jour la personne qui
lui sous le logement lui dit que le
propriétaire doit récupérer son bien
d'ici un mois congés vente Guillaume
fait une demande HLM cherche un logement
mais les prix des loyers la caution les
feuilles de salaire sur trois
générations qu'on lui demande Guillaume
n'y arrive pas il stresse tous les
matins de se retrouver à la rue mais ne
peut faire autrement selon vous
Guillaume est-il un squatteur Aurore à
71 ans elle est retraitée mais ne s'en
sort pas avec ses 900 euros par mois et
un loyer qui augmente chaque année
impayés procédure d'expulsion elle est
reconnue expulsable aurore est à une
voleuse
Elisabeth et son fils Bruno lou de
manière informelle un logement à
marchand de sommeil qui les arnaque ils
sont prioritaires DALO mais attendent
toujours sont-ils pour autant des
squatteurs
mes chers collègues je vous invite à
écouter l'orateur ou à minima
[Musique]
non je vous invite je vous invite s'il
vous plaît
à écouter l'orateur
et si vous souhaitez si vous souhaitez
avoir des échanges si vous souhaitez
avoir des échanges en bilatérale vous
sortez de l'hémicycle et vous allez
poursuivre la discussion en dehors de
l'hémicycle
monsieur pigman vous avez la parole et
vous merci chacun des collègues du
groupe provenance peut venir me voir
après plutôt que de donner un rectiver à
la tribune je finis mes exemples
Emmanuel et licencié de son travail il
doit quitter son logement de fonction
mais il ne sait pas où traverser la rue
pour trouver un abri Emmanuel est-il un
voleur en 2016 la rapporte spéciale de
l'ONU au logement les ilanifara
décrivait comment des grosses sociétés
immobilières captaient des immeubles de
logement et de bureau qui laissaient
vacants exprès pour spéculer dessus
alors on peut on peut se demander dans
cette loi quelles sont les mesures que
vous avez mises en place pour lutter
contre cela aidez-vous les petits
propriétaires bailleurs pour rénover
leur logement et les remettre en
location allez-vous taxer les
multipropriétaires qui laissent
sciemment des logements vides
comptez-vous utiliser la loi de
réquisition rien de tout ça pourtant la
loi de réquisition fait pleinement
partie de notre histoire républicaine
elle a été mise en place par le général
de Gaulle après guerre elle a été
utilisée pour accueillir les Pieds-Noirs
venus d'Algérie et par des gouvernements
de gauche comme de droite mais vous n'en
parlez jamais je me permets donc de vous
glisser ces paroles du rappeur Nekfeu
qui pourront peut-être vous y faire
penser dehors c'est froid il n'y a plus
d'humanité un homme est mort inanimé
devant un immeuble inhabité toutes les
heures toutes les 5 heures pardon dans
ce pays une personne meurt à la rue pour
un sans-abris dans ce pays il y a 10
logements qui sont vides votre loi
prétend lutter contre les squatteurs
mais on l'a vu cette dénomination
reflète de nombreuses réalités que vous
n'avez même pas pris la peine d'étudier
vous auriez pu auditionner d'une victime
de marchands de sommeil des locataires
en difficulté des locataires victimes
d'escrocs des gens s'étant réfugiés par
nécessité dans un logement vide vous
n'avez rien fait de tout cela vous avez
choisi les lobbies de l'immobilier et de
la spéculation à l'heure où les
locataires les charges d'énergie
augmentée vous allez ajouter une
pression dangereuse sur les 4 millions
de mal logés de notre pays et c'est là
le grand paradoxe c'est que vous créez
cette loi dans avec cette loi les
conditions pour que davantage de
personnes se retrouvent à la rue ce
n'est pas moi qui le dit mais un
responsable du Secours Catholique et
soit tenté d'entrer dans un des trois
millions de logements vides de notre
pays les squats c'est votre inaction en
matière de politique de logement qui en
est le terreau c'est le manque de moyens
pour les travailleurs sociaux du 115
dans les places d'hébergement d'urgence
le peu de logements sociaux construit
alors que la demande ne cesse
d'augmenter la coupe des aPL votre loi
va y ajouter de l'affaiblissement
considérable des tises positifs de
prévention des expulsions elle constitue
une attaque sans précédent à l'encontre
des droits et de la protection des
locataires et on sait que le mal
logement à coup humain important dans
l'accès à l'emploi à la santé à la
scolarité tout cela va peser humainement
et économiquement sur l'ensemble de la
société monsieur le ministre du Logement
c'est à vous que je m'adresse désormais
nous avons des désaccords c'est certain
mais je vous sais par votre parcours
sensible à la question du mal logement
et de vouloir poursuivre le chemin
insuffisant mais nécessaire du logement
d'abord cette loi va pleinement à contre
sens des intentions de celui-ci c'est la
Fondation Abbé Pierre qui le dit j'ai
cru comprendre par voie de presque vous
partagiez notre avis gagnons du temps
demandons aux rapporteur de retirer sa
loi parce que nous savons vous et moi
quelle est dangereuse pour des millions
de nos concitoyens dans un pays où la
crise du logement n'a jamais été aussi
importante depuis des décennies je
finirai monsieur le ministre chers
collègues par les mots de celui avec
lequel j'ai commencé l'abbé Pierre qui
je l'espère résonneront en vous autant
qu'il résonne en nous gouverner c'est
d'abord loger son peuple merci
parce que messieurs les ministres
vous souhaitez
prendre la parole non monsieur le
rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
peut-être réagir en deux mots ce qui
vient de dire monsieur pickman
vous avez dit c'est un phénomène qui est
un épiphénomène
mais heureusement
heureusement qu'on a pas des squatteurs
toutes les minutes dans toutes les
maisons de France dans tous les
appartements de France heureusement
qu'on a pas des situations d'un pays
dans tous les rapports locatifs
heureusement que ce sont des cas qui
sont minoritaires sinon il y aurait
d'ailleurs plus de marché locatifs
puisque personne n'oserait mettre en
location un bien immobilier si vous
savez que il y a une probabilité énorme
d'avoir un impayé mais pour autant même
si ce sont des situations qui sont
minoritaires et ce qu'on peut ne rien
faire et ce qu'on peut s'accommoder de
la situation actuelle est-ce qu'on peut
laisser des dizaines et des dizaines de
personnes dans des situations
déplorables parce qu'ils ont soit un
squatteur soit un occupant qui se
maintient pendant des années sans jamais
payer vous m'avez fait le reproche
monsieur bigmal de ne pas avoir
auditionné les squatteurs au cours de la
commission je le confirme je ne disne
pas des délinquants puisque le squat est
aujourd'hui un délit je ne vais pas
recevoir en commission des délinquants
en leur expliquant pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez squatté alors que le squat est
aujourd'hui pas juste dans ma
proposition de loi mais en général
aujourd'hui le squat est un délit et
c'est ça que vous n'arrivez à connaître
vous avez cité énormément de prénoms
énormément d'histoires je tiens à votre
disposition les dizaines et dizaines de
témoignages que nous avons reçus ceux de
Cléa de Jean-Loup de Bernadette d'Amélie
de Nîmes de Robert de Batman de Patricia
de Doriana di poli de Tiffany de
Jean-Philippe de Anne de Hervé tous ceux
qui nous ont écrit et qui témoignent de
leur difficulté ce sont des témoignages
écrits je les mets à votre disposition
monsieur pickman discutons-en et donc
rejetons cette motion de rejet préalable
monsieur le garde des sceaux
ce que je note une fois encore c'est que
vous êtes dans l'idéologie la plus
dogmatique qui soit je vais vous donner
un exemple l'article premier
l'article l'article premier bis pénalise
les marchands de sommeil vous nous
faites 5 minutes sur les marchands de
sommeil vous n'avez pas lu le texte
pardon vous ne l'avez pas lu maintenant
la grandeur d'âme l'abbé Pierre qui
devient votre référence moi j'aimerais
bien voir moi si on venait investir
votre domicile vous voyez que vous
rentriez chez vous qu'avec votre clé
vous ne puissiez plus rentrer on vous
entendrez
non non ça vaut pas pour les logements
sociaux mesdames la députée ça vaut pour
tout le reste
nous avons examiné plusieurs centaines
d'amendements et nous avons eu de bons
débats en commission des débats
productifs utiles qui ont permis de
largement amender et modifier ce texte
et vous savez
vous savez cette proposition de loi elle
est très attendue par nos concitoyens
il suffit d'ouvrir le journal tous les
jours pour voir que le concitoyens
on écoute sincèrement on écoute
l'orateur on a écouté la motion de rejet
qui a été proposée donc vous écoutez
madame rogol
je vous invite à ce que nous puissions
avoir un débat le plus sera possible
même si les avis sont contraires donc on
écoute monsieur midi et lui seul s'il
vous plaît et un débat serein c'est
important parce que cette proposition de
loi elle est très attendue par nos
concitoyens il suffit d'ouvrir le
journal tous les jours pour voir que nos
concitoyens sont trop nombreux à être
victimes de squats
qui sont sous le vent multirésidivistes
et donc évidemment
nous proposons de continuer le travail
de ne pas éviter les débats et surtout
mes chers collègues de tout faire pour
que cette proposition de loi soit
adoptée merci chers collègues essayons
de prendre un petit peu de hauteur
puisque finalement
le débat sur cette proposition de loi
c'est un débat entre deux principes à
valeur constitutionnelle d'un côté le
droit au logement de l'autre le droit de
propriété si nous défendons cette notion
de rejet c'est parce que nous
considérons que cette proposition de loi
rend l'équilibre juridique entre ces
deux principes constitutionnels cette
proposition de loi est en défaveur du
droit au logement et donc de facto en
défaveur des locataires des mal logés et
des personnes sans abri je le dis avec
gravité si cette proposition de loi
s'applique dans le contexte de crise de
logement que nous vivons je rappelle que
dans le pays il y a 300000 SDF 4
millions de personnes mal logées si
jamais cette proposition de loi
s'applique elle sera une véritable bombe
sociale une machine à fabriquer du
sans-abrisme voilà la réalité de cette
proposition de loi je vais tenter de
résumer les deux principaux points de
désaccord que nous avons avec le texte
issu des travaux de la commission
premier point de désaccord ce texte
réduit les marges de manœuvre du juge
dans la procédure d'expulsion et là
attention quand on parle du juge dans la
procédure d'expulsion on ne parle pas
des squatteurs on parle de personnes qui
sont rentrées dans un logement toutes
les qualités qui ont eu un bail qui ont
payé leur loyer mais qui sont confrontés
à des difficultés financières comme ça
arrive à des millions de Français on
parle même de locataires qui paye leur
loyer rubis sur l'ongle mais qui de fait
d'un congé-vente parce que leur
propriétaire veut vendre leur logement
les expulsent et bien dans cette
situation là vous réduisez le pouvoir
d'appréciation du juge vous réduisez la
durée des procédures d'expulsion et vous
empêcher le juge de faire son travail
c'est à dire de considérer la situation
sociale des familles pour éviter le
sans-abrisme et chers collègues moi je
suis très déçu des travaux en commission
parce que c'est un secret de
polichinelle de savoir que au sein de la
majorité et y compris vis-à-vis du
gouvernement que finalement monsieur le
ministre du Logement il ne défend pas la
philosophie de ce texte on le sait mais
malheureusement cela n'a pas permis de
faire évoluer le texte je finis madame
la Présidente en disant qu'il y a eu une
coalition sur ce texte entre la minorité
présidentielle le RN et LR
cette proposition de loi amalgame squat
de domicile squat de bâtiment vide et
locataire en impayés elle représente en
fait de graves recul du droit au
logement par un mélange de genre
dangereux entre le squat qui est une
occupation illicite on le sait d'un
logement après violation de propriété le
défaut de paiement d'un locataire qui se
trouve socialement danger vous assimilez
un locataire en difficulté à un
squatteur ce n'est ni moralement ni
politiquement acceptable avec cette
proposition de loi il y a une vraie
remise en cause d'un corpus de règles
patiemment élaborée et qui vise à
protéger la partie réputée la plus
faible du contrat le locataire tripler
les peines de prison pour des cas de
squat apparenter un vol d'occupation
sans droit ni titres permettant de
prononcer des peines jusqu'à 10 ans de
prison tout en réduisant les délais de
maintien dans le domicile accordé par le
juge personne vulnérables attestent de
votre volonté strictement pénitive pour
reprendre les mots du garde des sceaux
force doit rester à la loi il nous a
d'ailleurs donné des raisons
supplémentaires de la motion de rejet en
alertant sur plusieurs dérives du texte
et sur le très faible équilibre entre la
défense de la propriété et la défense du
locataire de son côté le ministre du
Logement renforcé des alertes il faut
trouver les moyens de renforcer les
logements d'urgence il n'est pas
possible de confondre mauvais locataire
et squatteur les locataires notamment en
situation de fragilité doivent être
accompagnés cette proposition de loi est
qualifiée de honteuse par toutes les
organisations d'aide au logement ATD le
Secours Catholique que Samu social
ce sont des militants peut-être ce sont
des militants qui chaque jour sont au
plus près de ceux qui sont en difficulté
c'est eux que vous devez aussi entendre
la seule question qui vaille c'est
est-ce que dans notre pays on est
capable de trouver un chemin pour
protéger les uns et les autres pour
protéger les propriétaires mais aussi
les locataires ou les personnes qui sont
en situation de mal logement or vous
utilisez un véhicule qui est une loi qui
est intitulée loin anti-squate qui est
une loi où on essaye de médiatiser des
situations qui sont gravissimes
scandaleuses mais exceptionnelle qui est
celui de la violation de domicile pour
lequel tout l'arsenal juridique existe
pour finalement durcir la législation
pour accélérer les expuls sur locatives
des gens qui sont en difficulté de
paiement c'est ça la réalité de cette
loi c'est pas la lutte contre les squats
et donc vous êtes en train de faire une
loi déséquilibrée qui va aller à
l'encontre des locataires et des et des
personnes en difficulté de logement pour
protéger des propriétaires pas les
petits propriétaires dont vous parlez
mais surtout les multiples propriétaires
qui font une rente de l'immobilier de
l'augmentation des loyers
d'autres députés dénoncent les failles
de la législation actuelle pour les
propriétaires dont le bien est squatté à
droite de l'hémicycle on soutien donc
cette proposition de loi du camp
présidentiel au passage l'extrême droite
dénonce l'hypocrisie de la nupesse et
les républicains ces outrances
le texte de loi s'inspire très largement
d'une proposition qui avait faite Marine
Le Pen sur le mandat précédent oui bah
oui pour remettre pour remettre la juste
question pour remettre la juste question
de l'occupation illégale des logements
qui fait un tel scandale auprès de la
population à justice titre deuxième
chose on ne supporte plus deuxième chose
oui enfin vous savez collègue de la
nupette ou votez très généralement pour
nous faire des leçons de morale avec la
majorité présidentielle donc cessé de
faire ses agitations quand ça vous
arrange alors que le lendemain vous
féliciter d'être avec la majorité votre
indignation est un géométrie variable
comme elle est agéométrie variable sur
le logement il est insupportable de
recevoir des leçons morales de la nups
le PS le Parti socialiste a largement
contribué à l'échelle de la politique du
logement en France depuis 40 ans vous
êtes co-responsable de ce que vous
dénoncez parfaitement correspondables
les Verts les écologistes sont
co-responsables madame Duflot a été
ministre du Logement voilà donc vous
faites semblant de découvrir des
situations à laquelle vous allez
participer vous dirigez un nombre
incalculable de collectivités
territoriales un nombre incalculable de
communes y compris de grandes
collectivités urbaines qui ont beaucoup
de moyens pour le logement vous êtes
correspondables de la situation que vous
déplorez les communistes ont congéré au
siècle le gouvernement café aussi les
Monsieur Mélenchon quand il était
ministre de Monsieur Jospin dans la
gauche pluriel a-t-il démissionné en
protestation de la situation de la
politique du logement en France jamais
donc vos leçons de Morales sur la
situation de logement en France sont
insupportables et vous opposez les
données de viande qui payent votre
faillite sur le logement aux zones qui
ont investi dans un logement et qui sont
victimes du laxisme judiciaire donc il
n'y a que le rassemblement national qui
défend les données de gants sur les deux
bords ce victime du mal aux mains à
cause de vous et ce victime du laxisme
judiciaire dont les logements sont
occupés donc nous voulons se débat nous
allons renforcer cette loi et tout ce
qui permet de défendre les petits
propriétaires nous le voterons merci la
parole est à Madame Geneva pour les
républicains
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur les ministres mes
chers collègues monsieur pickman vous
avez explosé votre propos en militant et
pas en législateur à militant un
militant qui ne craint pas l'outrange
vous avez commencé votre propos en
disant que
occuper un logement
squatter un logement c'est parfois pour
éviter la maladie et la mort comme si le
squat était un acte de légitime défense
deuxième exemple de transe lorsque
lorsque vous nous dites que
il s'agit par ce texte de protéger les
intérêts des spéculateurs des
multipropriétaires des escrocs je
reprends vos termes et des lobbies
immobiliers comme si
tout autre cas de figure n'existait pas
or les médias ne vous en déplaisent s'en
font régulièrement l'écho et vous ne
pouvez pas le nier troisième exemple
d'outrances lorsque vous dites que les
institutions ne font rien c'est comme si
depuis l'appel de la baie pierre durant
l'hiver 1954 il ne s'était rien passé
dans notre pays si la question du
logement était demeurer le point aveugle
de toutes les politiques publiques vous
le savez bien que c'est absolument faux
et s'il ne vous fallait ne vous donner
qu'un exemple je citerai la loi DALO de
2007 excusé du peu alors je crois que je
crois que c'est toute trans je crois que
c'est toute trans dessert profondément
votre propos oui les difficultés de
logement existent c'est vrai c'est vrai
et nous avons le devoir d'y répondre et
non seulement les élus nationaux que
nous sommes mais les élus locaux les
mers ne font que cela essayez de
répondre aux besoins de leur population
en matière de logement et ça n'est pas
facile bref
en aucun cas en aucun cas le mal le
logement ne peut légitimer le squat
c'est un raisonnement que nous ne
pouvons admettre ce n'est pas au petit
propriétaire d'endosser les conséquences
de la crise du logement et certains
squatteurs continuent d’ailleurs de
jouer avec les failles de la loi pour se
maintenir illégalement dans des
logements qui ne leur appartiennent pas
pour ces cas-là nous considérons qu'il
est nécessaire d'agir la loi ASAP avait
proposé de corriger quelques écueils
concernant la procédure d'évacuation
accélérée de logement par décision
administrative
cette proposition de loi vient combler
certaines lacunes elle précise qu'un
logement même vide de meubles peut-être
considéré comme un domicile elle opère
également une dissociation entre
l'introduction par voie de fait et le
maintien dans les lieux par voie de fées
de même le renforcement des sanctions à
l'égard des squatteurs va dans le bon
sens venons-en maintenant au disposition
relatives au rapport locatifs rappelons
que l'immense majorité des Français des
ménages français même dans les périodes
difficiles priorise l'acquittement de
leur loyer ceux d'entre eux qui ne
cessent qui cesse de payer n'ont souvent
aucun autre choix et ces situations
jusqu'à là exceptionnelle risque
malheureusement de se banaliser on en a
parlé l'inflation qui se répercute sur
le coup de l'énergie et des loyers rend
aujourd'hui difficilement soutenable et
fin de mois pour bon nombre de Français
et ce nestra une surprise pour personne
le risque d'impayé des charges et des
loyers va augmenter
aussi nous sommes favorables à la
transmission systématique par l'huissier
de justice du campement de pays à la
CAPEX afin de privilégier la prise en
charge la plus en aval possible des
difficultés du locataire c'est un
premier pas nécessaire pour accompagner
ceux qui sont en difficulté mais notre
droit est aussi par essence plus
protecteur de l'intérêt de la partie
réputée la plus faible locataire au
risque parfois d'oublier l'intérêt du
propriétaire aussi nous sommes
favorables à la réduction des délais
dans les procédures contentieuses du
traitement des impayés de loyer d'autant
que la réécriture en commission a permis
de rétablir une forme d'équilibre avec
la possibilité des co locataires de
réclamer au juge des délais
supplémentaires lorsque son relogement
ne peut se faire
reste le principal problème le manque de
logement disponible et abordable
qui ne fait toujours pas l'objet d'une
politique ambitieuse
proposition de loi anti-squate et voter
le 2 décembre 40 voie pour 13 contre
durant l'hiver l'inflation continue la
crise du logement s'aggrave la version
de la loi qui sort du Sénat est moins
sévère il n'y aura pas de prison pour
ceux qui restent dans un logement alors
que la justice ordonnée leur expulsion
fin mars retour à l'Assemblée le
ministre du Logement initialement
réservé sur cette proposition de loi
salut les modifications apportées par
les sénateurs tout comme son auteur
Guillaume kasbariian
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le texte que vous allez examiner ne
conduira donc pas les locataires en
impayés de loyer en prison et je m'en
réjouis il le réduira pas non plus
surtout pas l'accompagnement social
mieux il le stabilise il le clarifie et
il le déclenche plutôt dans la procédure
pour combattre dès que possible la
spirale de la pauvreté il n'empêche pas
le juge d'accorder des délais au
locataire qui peuvent payer leur loyer
mais qui ont été confrontés à une
période difficile le juge conservera
donc le pouvoir de juger au cas par cas
en fonction des demandes qui seront
faites par le locataire et de sa
situation financière
ce pouvoir du juge est gagnant-gagnant
gagnant pour le locataire qui peut se
maintenir dans le logement gagnant pour
le propriétaire à qui la dette sera
remboursée et le loyer payé sans
attendre une expulsion qui est toujours
pour moi pour vous un signe d'échec il
faut laisser le temps du travail social
il faut laisser au juge le pouvoir
d'analyser chaque situation d'être au
plus proche des réalités difficiles
d'une expulsion qui est toujours un
échec enfin cela me tenait à cœur ce
texte renforce les sanctions contre les
marchands de sommeil en tant qu' ancien
maire de Clichy-sous-Bois j'ai été
confronté à ceux qui indument organisent
des squats en faisant croire qu'ils sont
propriétaires des logements en toute
illégalité et au détriment des plus
faibles
cela s'inscrit d'ailleurs dans la lutte
du gouvernement contre l'habitat indigne
dont les procédures ont déjà été
renforcées et simplifiés par la loi Elan
adopter lors de la précédente
législature ce texte assure la juste
conciliation entre le droit à la
propriété et celui au droit au logement
deux droits essentiels qu'il ne faut
surtout pas opposer il permet de
protéger tant les propriétaires que les
locataires de bonne foi
mesdames et messieurs les députés pour
ma part je n'oppose pas lutte contre le
squat et l'occupation et illicites avec
une politique ambitieuse et sociale sur
le logement une politique du logement ne
peut pas être une politique du squat une
politique du logement ne peut pas être
une politique des impayés de loyer mais
une politique du logement doit répondre
à toutes les attentes légitimes
je le redis face au mal logement
l'objectif c'est l'accès à un logement
pérenne le gouvernement est pleinement
mobilisé je sais pouvoir compter sur les
députés de notre majorité pour y
parvenir cet acte passe par la politique
cet acte passe par la politique du
logement d'abord que nous poursuivons
cette année et que nous poursuivrons
l'année prochaine et l'année suivante
autant que nécessaire il applique
également de construire plus là où sont
les besoins afin que chacun puisse se
loger dignement et ainsi construire son
parcours de vie son parcours résidentiel
mesdames et messieurs les députés ce
texte a été
amélioré équilibré grâce à un travail
transpartisan des deux chambres il
témoigne de notre capacité à construire
des compromis au service de l'intérêt
général en réponse aux attentes
concrètes et quotidiennes des Françaises
et des Français je suis certain que nos
débats d'aujourd'hui permettront de
continuer à faire oeuvres utile et ainsi
préserver l'équilibre de cette
proposition de loi qui va dans le bon
sens et je vous invite donc à l'adopter
je vous remercie la hiérarchie des
peines n'était pas claire
certains cas de squats échappés à toute
définition légale et les seuls et les
situations locatives n'étaient pas
couvertes par les précédentes avancées
pour répondre à ce constat la
proposition de loi que nous étudions
repose sur une stratégie en trois
piliers le premier pilier de notre
action renforcera l'importance du
respect de la propriété privée dans
notre droit c'est pourquoi ces articles
étoffer au cours des débats je salue en
particulier l'extérieur travail des
sénateurs et de l'opposition sur cette
question
clarifie et élargissent le régime des
sanctions encourue que je rappellerai
très brièvement ici trois ans de prison
et 45000 euros d'amende pour ceux qui
squattent le domicile d'autrui c'est
l'article premier qui les sénateurs ont
adopté conforme deux ans de prison et
30000 euros d'amende pour ceux qui
souhaitent un autre local d'habitation
ou un local à usage économique c'est
l'article premier a et je salue le
travail de notre collègue Annie genvar à
ce sujet
trois ans de prison
trois ans de prison et 45000 euros
d'amende pour les marchands de sommeil
c'est l'article premier bis 7500 euros
d'amende pour les personnes qui se
maintiennent dans les lieux en dépit
d'une décision de justice définitive
c'est l'article 1er a et 3750 euros
d'amende pour les personnes qui incitent
au squat par la publicité ou la
propagande c'est l'article premier bis A
ces sanctions graduées et proportionnées
à la gravité des faits doivent permettre
de rassurer nos concitoyens sur
l'application de la loi échanger cette
impression d'une impunité dont certains
jouiraient le deuxième pilier c'est une
meilleure protection des victimes des
squatteurs souvent comme en ont à tester
les auditions que nous avons menées et
les centaines de témoignages que j'ai
recueillis depuis l'examen de ce texte
les personnes se sentent démunies
désemparés face à des personnes
malhonnêtes qui les gruchent de manière
systématique et abuse de leur
vulnérabilité c'est pourquoi la
proposition de loi contient les
évolutions suivantes fluidifier
l'expulsion administrative des
squatteurs en obligeant l'administration
fiscale à établir le droit d'une
demandeur et en permettant aux maires de
constater l'occupation illicite salut le
travail du groupe horizon sur le sujet à
l'article 2 et puis renforcer
l'indemnisation par l'état du
propriétaire lorsque le concours de la
force publique est refusé pour
l'expulsion des occupants c'est
l'article 6
au-delà des cas de squats le troisième
pilier concerne une zone grise celle
d'une minorité de locataires qui cesse
durablement de remplir leurs obligations
locatives il faut le répéter je crois
une écrasante majorité de locataire paye
leur loyer rubis sur ongles mais nous ne
pouvons pas passer sous silence ces
situations minoritaires ou des
locataires cesse de payer durablement
leur loyer j'entends que ce texte fait
hurler au sein de la nups mes chers
collègues mettez-vous à la place d'un
propriétaire aujourd'hui quel intérêt
a-t-il encore à investir dans
l'immobilier quel intérêt à garder en
location des appartements quel intérêt à
demander moins de caution moins de
certificats et moins de garantie dans le
contexte actuel ce texte constitue un
signal positif lancé en direction des
parties prenantes de l'offre de logement
sur la sécurité et la pérennité de leurs
investissements et nous en arrivons ici
au coeur à la raison d'être de ce texte
pourquoi nous préoccupons-nous
aujourd'hui de ces sujets
je vois les pancartes j'entends les
slogans j'écoute les attaques certains
disent que kasbariian est obtenues par
le squat d'autres disent que kasbariot
est insensible aux arguments de
certaines associations d'autres encore
prétendent que kasbariant n'a pas de
cœur d'autres enfin subit à tort que
kasbariant est multipropriétaires je
vous rassure tout de suite je ne suis
pas bailleur je ne possède que mon
domicile acheté à crédit une chaumière
dans un petit village d'oreloir près de
Chartres vous l'aurez compris cette
proposition de loi n'est qu'une des
briques d'une politique du logement plus
large elle ne remplace pas les
initiatives qui viendront mais elle
permet je crois de donner un signal fort
favorable à l'économie du logement
favorable à une politique qui vise à
augmenter l'offre de logements en
mobilisant le parc existant et en
incitant les particuliers à mettre leurs
biens en location nous aurons l'occasion
d'y revenir aujourd'hui dans les débats
et je l'espère dans les prochains mois
je vous remercie
lecture la gauche est toujours
réaffirme leur soutien cette proposition
de loi des macronistes
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
nous voilà donc à la lecture finale de
ce que vous auriez aussi pu appeler la
PPL C new BFM une proposition honteuse
qui vient en réaction au 170 170 cas de
squat dans notre pays et que la droite
est l'extrême droite récupère et utilise
pour stigmatiser toujours les mêmes les
plus pauvres et les étrangers comment
une majorité comme la vôtre peut-elle en
arriver à s'allier à la droite et au
rassemblement national pour voter un
texte si indigne et préoccupant pour le
droit au logement alors que ça vient
d'être rappelé 4 millions de personnes
sont encore mal logées dans notre pays
mais au moins chers collègues vous tenez
là la majorité derrière laquelle pour
désespérément votre première ministre je
le redemande quand même comment en avons
comment avons pu en arriver là comment
un président de la République élu sous
la bannière du progressisme en 2017
peut-il préférer criminaliser la
pauvreté plutôt que de chercher à
l'éradiquer en fait si on devait résumer
votre proposition de loi elle crée un
déséquilibre incroyable c'est que pour
vous un propriétaire a priori raison et
pour vous un locataire a priori tort
et ce faisant
ce faisant vous allez faire un cadeau
immense au marchand de sommeil et moi
qui suis un praticien des quartiers
populaires et de la politique du
logement je trouve que c'est une
véritable honte
il n'est pas étonnant de voir qu'une
fois de plus la nuit pêche veuille
rejeter un texte nécessaire pour
défendre les honnêtes gens et le droit à
la propriété tout en accompagnant les
locataires en difficulté c'est l'intérêt
de ce texte vous nous faites des leçons
de justice à longueur de journée mais
votre raisonnement est comme d'habitude
hors sol et profondément injuste vous
avez évoqué l'extrémisme hors sujet vous
avez opposé les locataires aux
propriétaires une nouvelle fois hors
sujet vous préférez défendre ce qui
agissent en parfaite illégalité au
détriment de ceux qui respectent les
lois de notre République et son nom de
facto des victimes il y a une crise du
logement en France et rarement on en a
construit aussi peu c'est une carence de
l'État mais pas que oui il y a bien des
difficultés pour se loger en France mais
là de quoi parle-t-on on ne parle pas du
droit au logement il n'y a pas de droit
il n'y a pas de droit à occuper
illégalement un logement qui n'est pas
le sien
c'est une occupation illégale on vise
aussi des
occupations de mauvaises foi alors sur
certains rangs on défend évidemment les
squatteurs contre le petit propriétaire
qui est un affreux capitaliste on se
fiche pas mal du fruit de ces années de
travail on les cache chers
collègues vous n'empêchez pas vos
collègues d'exprimer leur point de vue
on vous a écouté dans le silence j'ai
demandé le silence pour votre
intervenant vous écoutez Philippe
Gosselin il y aura un débat vous ne
couvrez pas la voix de l'orateur non
vous ne couvrez pas la voix de l'orateur
c'est un principe on respecte les
orateurs ça va monsieur Corbières gosla
vous avez la parole et vous seul merci
monsieur le président
je disais donc que le droit au logement
ne donne pas le droit d'occuper un
logement illégalement celles et ceux qui
squattent savent pertinemment qu'ils
occupent illégalement des logements
les députés retouches à peine la copie
du Sénat et l'Assemblée vote très
largement en faveur de la proposition de
loi de renaissance
[Musique]
alors je vais mettre on voit la
proposition de loi
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
votant 540 exprimé 532 majorités 277
pour 385 contre 147 l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté
[Applaudissements]
monsieur monsieur le garde des sceaux
vous avez la parole
mes chers collègues si vous quittez je
vous invite à le faire en silence et
sommes-nous sur garder soit la parole
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
c'est une première marche mais ce soir
vous avez mis un terme de façon trans
partisane à une injustice que nos
compatriotes ne supportent plus ils sont
en effet révoltés et eux ne confondent
pas les locataires et les squatteurs il
était important de rappeler que les
squatteurs sont des délinquants il est
important que l'on protège les
propriétaires et puis la dernière sauce
que je veux vous dire c'est que je suis
toujours sidéré d'entendre un
parlementaire appelé à la désobéissance
civile c'est-à-dire la désobéissance à
la loi
qu'il est parfois censé voter
les sénateurs font pareil quelques
semaines plus tard la loi pour lutter
contre les squatteurs et définitivement
adopter mi-juin c'est la fin de cet
épisode des grands débats merci et à
bientôt sur LCP
[Musique]